the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
open honest and issues and each time
that you guys visiting imagine even
remember me nagging me to to get deeper
into personal issues and not just be
abstract and the reason is because I
think you make it is very key whatever
you want to talk you can bring your own
breath into it I think it and I still
you know there's so much for the
semester from listening to some of your
own personal discoveries about your
structure but issues of race language
gender equality and I give you lots of
is risky and before you came here that
know each others of you write them and
yet to be able to
get yourself to be difficult questions
and to get answered that person 12 fuel
and and so many of them actually giving
spectrum of literally canal
so maybe keep your things that you feel
with you so that you feel that others
will come after you newsflash my benefit
from it was to share
[Music]
yeah so I'm not sure if I fully
understand what else to say but say what
I was thinking um so for me personally
clear out this class I think I realized
I like explored myself and like my
identity way more and I think I was
forced to ask questions about myself
that I hadn't and for me the main thing
I realized is like how uncomfortable I
am with being multiracial like I enjoy
being multiracial but realize that
there's parts of me but like don't
necessarily fit together and how like I
don't really see myself as one certain
race or whatever and I think you know
the things that helped with that were
like you know our personal essays and
like the definitely the free writing
assignment that one of the guest
professors had us do like that cut
pretty deep and like I was kind of like
oh crap
after rated like 9:30 in the morning
when she first said that but then like I
really enjoyed it as I went on and I
think like maybe bringing out more
multiracial ink topics next year would
be beneficial to people like me like
that was like a problem and I think like
also a really interesting topic that we
went over it was like I think it
wouldn't be calling fake you know
passing passing and like how that's a
privilege and like talking about like
all the controversial issues on that and
I think I really also thought about that
for this class so that was something I
benefited from okay so you
speaking to the passing yeah in that
minute we are becoming at 50 at mid back
then right at often when we think of
passing the Kabira something which is
negative you tell me that point in time
will be aware that was very important
that that momentum is a way that one can
think of passing as we know more
survivability so in so I guess it's a
report I think yeah
but just
this class has serviced a little
factories the importance of
conversations
and so I think most of the learning that
I've done
in this class and other sort of seminar
based classes pales in comparison or
what I learned my technical courses
bills and operations it means
like this because that the end of the
day I think most of the learning comes
from those around you your classmates
this experiences that they have more so
that we learn from these technical
classes there's a saying that says like
five years after you graduate remember
90 percent or whatever
to college but I think what you do
remember is sort of these sort of
conversations that boil down to personal
experiences and so I think again there
is challenge in this world of sort of
approach
we aren't really want
have these conversations but sort of
changing yourself is the first step and
I think if everyone sort of makes this
has this realisation it takes a step
towards making this change
it's very idealistic but I think
I think that's probably one
bouncing off of what Burke said I think
one way which I would like to see this
class grow is the integration of having
some sort of conversation like open
discussion inside a debate with someone
who does not come from a similar
theological thank ideological background
as most people in this clash to try to
see to sort of gain practice in having a
session with someone who's a lot
different from you and developing a
common trust and coming to see each
other's viewpoints in a way that would
be more important than what one could do
among a set of like-minded individuals
let's see so one thing that I enjoyed
about this class I can distinctly
remember what what class it literally
blew my mind I think I turn to something
like oh my gosh
and that was when we interrogated what
MIT was as an institution and where we
sit in this field and this hierarchy of
social you know from the social
hierarchy in the US and I think what
coming to MIT I was willing to give the
institution of free pass a lot because I
felt that I was getting a lot from the
experience but I think now that I'm a
senior and all the seniors here rather
last minute classes now that I'm at this
point where I can think back on what MIT
has done for me and what and how it
functions I think I'm better poised to
think more critically about institutions
I choose to join in the future for a
postgraduate education and
so I took this class as a challenge to
myself because at the beginning I knew
about the prejudices and stereotypes
that I had been taught and I wanted to
get rid of them and I think this class
has helped a lot with that just by
hearing everyone else's perspectives
from the readings from looking at the
world by taking a step back and like
looking at things as they are and not
how we were specifically taught that
they are and I really appreciate that I
want to like from here on I want to like
move forward to try to figure out how
like how to be an ally from an
asian-american perspective because a lot
of the times Asian American families try
to be the status quo like my parents
have always taught me to like try to be
not explicitly but implicitly like try
to be as white as you can and I think
that that was a really difficult lesson
to go through and then come to a place
like MIT which is so diverse and which
has so many different backgrounds and to
like come in thinking there's a
hierarchy where there isn't and now
going forward trying to break that down
um related to what you said actually is
you know this concept of being
multiracial and interrogating that for
yourself but also within a context of
being in a society of multiple races and
understanding the spaces that exist for
for meaningful conversations across
cultural and ethnic and other sometimes
just socially constructed boundaries
that don't necessarily meet to be
boundaries and I remember in one
conversation you know Cynthia actually
really challenged you know this idea of
forming alliances especially between
historically systematically oppressed
groups and you know in a class like
black matters I think that we we
actually think about people who who
don't identify as black and who may not
be red as black in society and we we've
engaged critically with the issues that
they face as well you know when we
talked about immigration in from Mexico
and you know the times where I insist
upon interjecting indigenous North
American issues under the conversation
but there seems to be space for all of
that and so what I want to take away
from all of these discussions is how can
we create meaningful alliances and be
allies and how can we collaborate
between groups who who are distinct and
different and face similar challenges in
in this society but also have really
specific perspectives and experiences
and future goals so the idea of
collaborations especially among
historically oppressed groups is one
that I want to continue thinking about
outside of this class a lot of what I
was thinking about during this class for
me personally was comparing and
contrasting because I come
from very I'm from Zimbabwe so there's
not a lot of diversity and this was an
entirely new experience to me so a lot
of what I was doing was comparing my
past my history my experiences with you
guys experiences and everything around
me and thinking about for instance in
the readings how they analyze different
situations of situation America the
situation in Haiti and thinking about
where these things are connected how
they are different what clip and then
what should be done and I think I really
thought about issues like this before
this class and now I'm starting to think
about it more especially in education
I'm really interested in education and
how we can help teach people in the
future how to use their skills that they
learn how to think about certain things
how to approach certain problems in a
way that challenges them and also
challenges the status quo and challenges
is the hierarchies that I set up so
personally I think that this class
definitely helped me think a lot more
and I hope that in future it will help a
lot more people think about their
actions think about what they're saying
think about what they're doing and think
about how they can help and how they can
engage their communities for instance I
remember when we're talking about how we
we came to MIT we might graduate and
then how what are you going to do when
we go back to the communities where we
come from but how are you gonna how do
we plan to affect those communities do
you go back as experts or do we go back
as one of them do we try to fit in like
questions like that or definitely things
that we should think about and
yeah I think the biggest thing for me
was like learning about what we were
learning but then thinking back to how I
grew up in like a really white area and
I was always taught like there's one
correct way to speak there is like one
correct way to teach kids and like
thinking back now with like all this
information on how damaging that really
is and how it's not really about the
language and it's not really about how
we think it's more about marginalizing
groups that might speak that way and
it's like just thinking about how like
my entire school system was based on
like what they thought was correct and
what was Talent telling us what we
should think it's correct and I think
coming out of this hopefully we can try
to change some of that in the school
systems because it can really affect how
kids view the world
as they grow I think one thing I gained
from this class is kind of I guess some
verification of the idea that listening
is like very important and it's there's
kind of various ways you could think
about it like just in the context of
this class whether it's like listening
to like other people share their
experiences and like kind of really
taking in and understanding like how
they fit in within like whatever social
hierarchy or whatever kind of issue were
discussing and seeing how it's kind of
played a role in their lives and kind of
seeing how you can apply it to either
better or someone else's life like
improve your own kind of interaction
with the world in some way or whether
it's listening in terms of like language
you talk a lot about language and like
kind of how certain modes of speaking
our somewhat marginalize so ensuring
that like as you go forward you
really listen to people regardless of
how they present their ideas or present
their thoughts or whether it's like
listening as far as like engaging people
who have opposing opinions as you like
really understanding that in order to
strengthen your own positions and really
understand why it is that you think the
way it is you have to be able to listen
to people who kind of think in a
different way than you so yeah I've just
seen a lot of kind of different things
in this class that speaks to importance
of listening lack of analysis of my
racial background like because I'm
japanese-american it's not really
something that like I'm forced to
address all the time because no one's
really calling that much attention to it
because neither one of those groups is
really that attacked even like modern
society as like before like being a
racial group and like something I didn't
even think about my mom is an immigrant
I didn't really address that ever
because no one was calling me to
question her immigration here and that
also leads to a lot like relating to how
like other the opinions of other people
and especially like my very conservative
extended fan
on how their opinions about certain
things such as immigration are reliant
on people being of certain races and
being from certain places because there
isn't something that they've ever seen
negatively about my family but it is
something that Sakura why my family
exists so I think things like that like
me having people address their own
identities in their own backgrounds and
how that's affected how they see
everything else by interaction
I'm having trouble distilling everything
down but I guess one big takeaway from
this class was that accepting that
there's no one right way to exist as
like a human across like generalization
oddly race class and things like that
and that was a realization that I think
I came to in this class and it all goes
back to like the importance of
interrogating your beliefs and why you
think the ways that you do and it's
really eye-opening it's really important
but you have to open yourself up to that
and it takes like like I wasn't
expecting to come out at all but I did
because this was a place where I think
about the same it was like really
surprising that I felt so safe in this
in this environment and
something that we need to recreate
elsewhere another thing that I would
like to take for this plastic in the
future is like therapy pool bar at
seniors if you have thoughts like what
do you do now do you take the next or
like what actions can you take because
further than the boss and I think
something that maybe happened in this
class is thinking about concrete ways to
do stuff because yeah professor Chomsky
here on Tuesday and he said almost
anything is the answer to like what do
we do
so maybe having some sort of initiative
like coming out of this classes to make
change maybe just added my teeth or just
like awesome
so kind of piggybacking off of hooker
said I think the most meaningful
conversations and talks that we've had
for me where when we talked to
professor's people
Oliver Cambridge who were using their
own backgrounds their own fields of
study and they're making tangible
changes as Chris is saying so for
example when we watch the like the
virtual reality kind of simulation in
terms of the israeli-palestinian
conflict and I feel like those
conversations and the fact that I have
to have the privilege of taking this
class in my last semester has really
kind of driven me to really like to take
action outside of MIT and hopefully in
the future back at MIT and to really
take that with me in my specific field
so medicine and how these various
identities can really affect people's
kind of healthcare and and and that's
that's life or death and and so I feel
like that that has really been
eye-opening for me and that's kind of
driven me to to action
you know I think for me from this bias
made me more aware of how many things
for example what I didn't know about the
each of evolution was it occurred and I
didn't reading you know question it
granted time but it's all the things
that we aren't taught just because a lot
of the history that we learned or it's
talking like a very honest Western
expert perspective so I feel like it's
very important that this class teaches
that there's always many ways to view
certain things and there's certain many
things that aren't necessarily just
because because society just doesn't
want us to know about these things
so that we cover
be similar to
[Music]
taking action and a lot of partner
meetings like
just like oh that's really strange but I
guess that's just the way things are
it's like to know that things are wrong
but you didn't do anything just trying
to take action and many dimensions like
interrogating yourself is an important
way to do it
that just thinking of my whole life in
terms of the languages I grew up reading
writing and how they represented to me
was a really good way just to to look
into my own self
what I think would have been would be
better and future versions of this boss
would be maybe talking together in
smaller groups
I guess I think it's easier just to talk
about yourself for some people
I think the only time we got to do that
was last Tuesday
[Music]
thank you I think
so what just it also giving my parents a
you know so what Christine can try
together because this class I hope will
be offered many many many many times
again here and actually we're thinking
of next year and I get with Pharaoh so
from that perspective maybe you guys
could share with me what you think will
be done to implement what you guys think
in terms of taking is knowledge and into
action because Travis mister I was
reading it wet enough projects do I sign
because I often thought that would be so
nice a good project that puts you guys
in the world not just reading an essay
you know and I try to see whether
something could come up spontaneously
from you that's good ultimately where I
want to do this so why don't you advise
me in the next back of this course to
make that happen
go to to do projects women throughout
the semester on the intern or optional
projects that will really turn knowledge
into passion
so maybe something's like I still think
you should have the essays cuz at least
for me they were pretty beneficial in
exploring myself yeah but maybe instead
of having like the essay revision
although I think like revising essay is
important I think that could be done
throughout your essay process is dead
and maybe like putting in a project
where you have to create like a policy
or like a lesson plan or like something
like that and then present that and
maybe even have a plan of action of who
he would go to talk to about this cuz I
think like if you just come up with a
plan it can be pretty like you know
philosophical or just like just an idea
and we'll never be done with it but like
what would be your next step now you
have an idea how do you implement it and
then also something I forgot to mention
before it I thought was really useful
about this class was when we went to go
to the movies all together on a Saturday
and at first I was like oh crap now I
have to like a lot a lot of time but I
actually really enjoyed that and was
hoping the conversation would keep going
okay so maybe having more things outside
the class because I think it's really
hard to explore all the things that you
would want to do in an hour and a half
right so like maybe having somewhere
like I don't know what types of places
you can go to but maybe going to a you
know an inner-city school in Boston
together and like seeing how it stopped
there and what you would change actually
because one thing that I'm told meet
with folks
Harold is to see whether we could change
the format of having an area hat
once a week for three hours and in the
past I tried that but because of the
schedule get my teeth in art for
students to enroll if you are a classic
undergraduate so we stepped away from
that but now we think not whether we
should do that happen and then many
three hours you could go something else
yeah I make it beneficial I know like
negotiation absalom does a Thursday I'd
like five or something like that so it's
hard to schedule like a three-hour class
during the day but if you do it as a
night section okay okay people think
that if he said okay how many ossified
would be difficult cause there's a lot
like no athletes the partition biggest
play practice from side to side okay
yeah there's another section at 7:00
pretty sure yeah yeah talking about
projects and I think that could
definitely work in this course I think
one thing that I've really wanted is to
be able to affect change in this within
the context of its course and sort of
have a reason to do so
based on readings I would like to go
into school and say you know let me try
my hand and teaching kids and this lens
even actually worse so if you want to
organize that sort of thing it could be
cool to also work in small groups and
maybe diversified I mean we have a ton
of the courses in here but I think
there's a lot to be gained I'm working
going out into the real world and I
think I mean this is just me great but I
think a three-hour course would be good
what Collin said about
it's common courtesy to
so going back to the last points in
terms of into the school had some good
news which is that I think I should have
better cope with you about this new
program between lounge in the cosmetics
go into a news program and Vivienne Tam
typically shiny and Shashi she launched
chat lounge the Tongass program Chinese
English and can be between visibly well
right here and it is also accessible for
watching this serial English strongest
program it is offered that if their
student in this class and other category
they want to come and volunteer and and
the advantage of that new program in
terms of doing any research especially
day so I break
to do with measuring students learning
games she'll be happy to work with you
it's one student in my other class was
the inspector with who still get out
twice and wanting to be going on a
weekly basis to the meetings to try to
understand how they are creating this
new program where there'll be I think
half kids who speak real and absolute
cosmic real and truly that angle so we
get American or other abilities learning
some clear indication for kids because
it was very English and be community so
I think it's it is really very very cool
if I always programs of that sort but
never one involving in non impure
language the debates in Spanish English
French English Chinese English the first
character doing one that in
in the years as you know demonized a
tree so we we excited this it's on push
back including respect from location
parents told them who prefer to a bit
French imaginary over the dog big sense
that it's a typical neo-colonial
information into theory language but I
think the late means of good progress
Chomsky was here to say he had an
integer capital my Facebook page
activity where we cost me him and the
tenets of the little disagreement its
past as well
she grew up in California and it was a
very interesting exchange before the two
of us we're just asking about the
importance of promoting local
ingredients or mini collaboration of the
skills of the time so I suggested the
very suggestion and since parallel is
yes it's from background the competition
and as you saw the project working with
reality that might be an intelligent
cause we're in the action with the just
basically so it like the Fox Herald
computation part I thought it was really
interesting like learning about what
he's doing but I think if there was like
like I don't know if this is where you
were going but like if I think there was
a if there was more part of it to do
more computation based things I'd
probably put it straight away because
like so I'm not like the started to be
major here like I'm a business major but
I think I would have been like slightly
intimidated if there was like a CMS type
project in here so maybe like making
that one of the facets of what you can
do but not a requirement
the learning styles of the students in
the class can be interesting so maybe
doing more creative projects are doing
projects that people feel like allow
them to use their their best skills if
you present project that was creative as
we get back to just after fly I maybe
would have
like okay and then and then that's not
the part that includes communication or
focus or so how would you do that so we
would develop the habit of people
describing why you didn't the mission of
what you've done and I mean if it was
just like a black body or like a like a
brown body was I'm sorry I would even
just leave Marcus and stuff for other
people to put message I'm on it and be
like
like giving any cart is a great way to
give people
and to have those conversations I can
watch it with Pharaoh and actually
anyone has so our customer this i don't
maybe you think that psychology gender
grades the sava a psychologist who works
in the local area out there alright
first name should be a great last name
but now the part of the class is like
training earth like doing my training
how to present cultural awareness
presentations where you go with you
basically one group of students and kind
of teach the other students for a role
playing had to like college frat members
of college grad or like sixth grade
instead of local bus and public school
about like different about how some
things that that may be doing could be
disparaging to minority groups and it
could be interested in having
conversation we're here to see like what
things she incorporates into those
presentations and if useful in some
black matters okay
that's abuse
I think it's another way for us to
communicate like as students because
just like that was really interesting
like something that we already all use
and wouldn't have to go out of our way
so you're asking what kind of projects
right so from like the teaching
perspective I think after the classes
last week learning about open and fixed
my yeah open a fixed mindset something
that would have been interesting as the
project would be to create a curriculum
with just a lecture or a workshop for an
age group whatever age it could be
college it could be lower and kind of
trying to implement
like teaching techniques that we learn
to foster a more open mindset that would
have been a cool like project to explore
okay okay okay okay I think I think it'd
be that we've an idea also we can still
think that will give us a little more
when you actually go into these schools
and say now we'd like to bring this plan
to you because we have professor backing
we have this whole slew research behind
us
another cool thing that you could do
about like community outreach is I know
one time a couple weeks ago in
amphibious achievement we had a bunch of
people from chocolate City come in and
also it's there's a group it's like
something-something Latinas and I don't
know with my head started yes yeah so
they came in and chocolate soda came in
and we it's a program at MIT and we work
with Boston public high schoolers and
it's like an academic mentorship program
but also we just like work with them to
try to build their confidence and we
also help them apply to college and
things like that but in the chocolate
city is like just like a it's a living
group here on campus and it's like
african-american man and then look at
this that's women and so they came in to
talk to the high schoolers in amphibious
achievement and we just had like a
discussion about how they feel about
what they've been told they can and
cannot do because of like they are and
it was really really interesting for
everybody and I think that would be
something cool to do like a Facebook
page we do
thank you would 15 be a better week with
me getting yeah boy yeah yeah we might
we better so give me thank you the
nurses created Facebook page for the boy
yeah a patriot of course and then for
the students and they are we that's
given one time just explained um
bouncing on the air they I think it'd be
really interesting like you can actually
have one heart I happen to be like a and
men support emancipatory literacy like
class presentation or something where
you like take a certain section
literature maybe just one book like
Madame Bovary and dissect the ways in
which the society in which it is
embedded create the themes and within it
like many good things that amount ago
grades like the Senate on this one woman
who's like married and the countryside
of France back might be 19 or 18
hundreds and she gets really depressed
because she has nothing to do and just
explaining it like she has no options
for employment and it's stuck at home
because that's what was expected of
woman back in that day and like
dissecting both that cultural phenomenon
then it's like examining how that may
play out in like today's terms with
different patterns and society
Wow okay oh this is something that I was
thinking about was what you had said
about having like an art project and I
realized I'm not a psychic level so I
was trying to figure out what I would do
if there was in our assignment and I was
thinking about something that's in a
show we're like you put yourself up like
you stand up there and then you have
like a projector screen and you write
words on it of what you don't like about
yourself and that could be like instead
of like what we don't like about
ourselves like things we've been told
about ourselves based off our race or
based on your gender or sexuality then
also having things that you would rather
have been said because I what I really
like about this class with the self
exploration
[Applause]